hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to nuclear power plant
simulator where you I'm assuming play as
a Homer Simpson type character in charge
of way too much important [ __ ] oh god I
have no idea what at home oh good
there's so many buttons there's so many
lights keep the lights green Oh God
well that seems simple enough but maybe
I should read the instructions hello
there are three reactors on the panel
for each one every reactor has three
controllers red core temperature green
reduces the temperature of the reactor
increases the heat exchanger blue
reduces the temperature oh my god
find the perfect balance between these
values to produce an amount of megawatts
required figure out by yourself with the
best values you have to pie boo-boo-boo
target 150 megawatts produce less and
you're fired produce [ __ ] you're fired
why produce more oh god okay routine
checks you'll sometimes receive
instructions do them within 40 seconds
if you're late something breaks aah [ __ ]
boss a meter I made the technical staff
install an indicator on the management
panel that shows you how close you are
to being fired it should be standard in
every workstation oh my god Oh decide I
want to disappoint you boss how do I get
out of here
okay I don't know how to do this but
I'll try
routine controls have been habited have
it have it
point point point point um that's good
right confirm [ __ ] I don't know how to
do that oh there was flippy switches up
top Oh God oh that's for that later okay
so we need to UM pop some umm Pidge ooh
ah that's nice
oh that's nice okay all right is this
good I don't know if it's good or bad
the numbers seem to be exponentially
increasing are there ever gonna stop
yeah it seems okay except the reactor
core seems to be heating up quite a bit
okay but that's good so we each have
individual three panels but they're all
the same thing so long as I can people
was beeping little bomb Oh God oh hello
Oh Oh God Oh 17 oh geez
ah geez Oh God hey yeah what was that
see down down down down down down down
down down was it one more down yet one
more down
boink and then yellow alright yeah there
we go yeah what did that not do it
Oh God oh forget it good
what is this on fire Oh God look
terrible out there oh I'm not doing all
[ __ ] god damn it what the [ __ ] was I
supposed to do in case of fire deal with
it ah [ __ ]
hey let's read it again that one
terribly oh good golly okay let's try
this again but a little less stupid very
light lots of coolant to ramp up the
coolant so it stays nice and cool I
think that was my problem before like I
was I wasn't doing enough cooling cuz I
gotta be mindful of that make sure the
pressure doesn't blue oh geez oh geez oh
geez oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god
things fine everything's fine
oh geez oh geez oh geez oh geez okay no
instructions yet okay everything is fine
everything is hunky-dory look at
everything going over there everything
is great I love my job I love my life
well I'm a job life life job please
don't fire me okay uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
okay whoa all right that's looking a bit
dangerous
we need to amp up production a little
bit oh geez oh geez oh geez hello Oh 45
all right down down down uh okay oh god
damn it that's all wrong [ __ ] oh god
what was the red one yeah that was
ribbon
poink okay got it got instructions
everything looks good we need a lot more
power we're not doing enough holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] so heat exchanger up topic
Purdue what happened
Wow Wow that [ __ ] happen oh yeah oh
god oh god oh god everything's fine
everything's fine everything's fine okay
everything's fine
oh yeah what sucked how the [ __ ] am I
supposed to know what I'm doing
Oh God okay all right so we need to
increase pure more pure more or coolant
we're a coolant power we can do more
power we can do a lot more power we're
doing great we're doing really good on
power so everything is hunky-dory don't
know why this is so goddamn flammable Oh
was it oh god one 8500 precision okay
boink
okay got it I'm good I'm smart okay so
I'm not quite at my target I need a
little more I still need more I need
this coolant reactor core go up quite a
bit little more a little more baby a
little more that might've been too much
ah I want too much is something gonna
catch on fire everything seems Green
Green Green Green this is a lot more
stressful than I imagined it would be
Oh nuclear is dripping from the ceiling
okay but I think I have a better handle
on this so hopefully you guys didn't see
me panicking like a stupid idiot and now
I've actually got a better grasp on it
okay so this crease of cool in just a
little bit both of those more coolant
please
and then I guess oh I get it now okay so
the more I cool it the less heat is
actually produced and heat is actually
what gets the power I've got too much
okay so we need to knock it down a bit
whoo [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god alright
bye bye bye bye bye okay we're good
alright so I need to knock down the
power a bit I can actually take this one
down whoa hello 205 you got it
boink got it okay did it good all right
so we're close I'm just gonna knock this
down just a little more this should work
or I could increase the coolant which
would prevent more heat from getting to
them what fired
what fired I was just getting it what do
you mean fired what a bunch of dill weed
holes what a bunch of Jack bastards
god damn it [ __ ] your anus all right
fine I'll do this better now that I
actually understand this should be a
little better I ride out right all right
so the secondary coolant could be like a
direct connection to everything that we
need 323 323 a double green [ __ ] okay
and then all over the flippies just one
down you got it
boy okay so we got this year I'm gonna
bring the secondary coolant down even
more down even more down even more or
zet that's dropping the power so why Oh
what whoa so that's like a really direct
can wash it now it's on fire goddamn and
not the instruction manual okay so then
bringing this down or up oh geez why is
bringing the coolant up making more
power fascinating so I have to make
exactly a hundred and fifty that seems
oddly specific wink okay got it
yeah boss a meter I'm about to be fired
I'm trying it's just they're coming in
on different levels okay bring up the
reactor core bring up the reactor core
uh-oh we're on target Oh stay on target
stay on target
huh too much huh too much come on too
much
go down down down no that's the
opportune to what I wanted
Oh God that was the opposite where's it
going down why is it not going down go
down damn it
suck it dick go down
oh I gotta beat this I gotta beat this I
gotta beat this go down damn it go down
damn it god damn it
[ __ ] you 352 god damn it one no down
down down to what alright oh [ __ ] here
we go okay what is this good dammit what
the [ __ ] what the fack okay that go up
that stay up that stay do you do too
much okay stay right the [ __ ] there yes
yes yes fine fine okay stay right now
[ __ ] they're right on target cuz I'm a
baller I know exactly what I'm doing
boss a meter oh boy
that looks like I'm about to be fired
but why would I be about to be fired
everything is good everything is hundred
percent good I'm out of time yet oh geez
[ __ ] if I heard [ __ ] fire got it okay
so now that I got that everything seems
to be nominal I could raise up a little
bit of something else a little bit of
something else
okay okay point okay got that well no
why are we going down why are we going
down why are we going down why are we
going down why why why why are we going
down don't go down don't go down don't
be stupid
Oh boss a meter does it looks better I
guess looks better oh this is a panic
okay but we're doing good okay I think
we've actually got it under control now
because now that the power is being
relatively nominal and everything seems
to be green across the board
I don't think we're gonna have any more
problems and I don't think anything is
gonna blow oh god damn it things are
blowing up [ __ ] oh [ __ ] now reactor
core on three is being over utilized his
number three for some reason as being
way way overdone I don't know what that
means and I don't know how to stop it
but I think I only have one hour left so
if these guys can just hold out for one
more hour then we're gonna be okay if
everything could stop lighting on fire
that'd be lovely okay we need to up whoa
Oh God
what the [ __ ] I didn't even get to read
what it said I [ __ ] it was already mid
click god damnit [ __ ] wanted it say I
don't even get to read it ah put it up
put it up put up what it was that's
interesting information that I would
have loved to have read yeah okay but
that was power plant simulator so that
was a bit of fun but it got a bit
tedious after a while but still if you
want to reenact the life of Homer
Simpson feel free to play this game for
yourself I I'm actually surprised this
seemed to only be one level to it I
didn't know it would be like that but
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video oh look at that
6s jar of mayo